Caught in some way they are after i got to go in and it is in. Train sickly egg. I mean if i can be right.
Their relationship between freedom and community. Is.
Of course so intense that my stokley needs to talk about i've affected as well.
You know order to get more of a secular view instead of a polarize ation.
You can look at the name
and experience as being one way of people came with an ideal of being very communal sharing everything
and have gone full circle and become. Family. Suburban and separate families. But also within the first three months.
Of town a befalls. That was separate has is being started. After much discussion. Much talk.
There was simply the no you don't die get is and mandy get this is pot. To have. I separate spice.
Because they had children. The force of children. Drove them to stop. Work on the first independent.
New hass at autonomy force. And just to not be so troublesome.
Not just for themselves but for other people because children really really want to a huge amount of their.
Spice their privacy and their ownership of their parents that when those parents come through the door. They're there.
With does children. And very quickly. It became. Well as soon as that started with and. I came to the can.
Luzhin of bringing in the wood hammer us. And of and of saying look this gang.
This is going to happen all over the place about. Let's try to have those houses being built in clusters of houses.
Let's call them hamlets. And let's try to get those to work together in a particular area.
And to share some of the land together. And maybe their fruit crops or certainly their access. And whatever.
Things that they want to share together. Let's just encourage people to share. The us by the block.
If you're thinking in terms of the city. You'd mess like we'd be looking at all the backyards in one particular block.
Or you might be looking at the. In some streets of the front yards and. In a street. Because the street is in fact.
More a part of the place. Than the back out. At any right. That started. And we we had these hamlets going.
Right away there was that level of privacy. Right away at the beginning there was always i.
Privacy in people's economics. There was no. Sharing of money you know why the sense. And.
It's just as likely that in the future. Niemann will be count more. Communal.
In terms of the work that people are doing together. Because when people are building their own houses. And that.
Sharing a bit of life with a child or but they're basically they're building their own houses.
In that phase that they're very isolated. And that's communal in many ways. So i think that. Time. Newman.
Might become more sharing. And hopefully with that. It might in fact.
Be more willing to worry about its common problems. Its community problems.
And to share responsibility for those community problems and to actually step in and take action about those. What's.
What is. I suppose for me as a writer. In women. There is a lot of individuals.
It's a lot of people who don't fit into. Easy molds and. There's a lot of people who while.
Often falling into very normal suburban. Patterns. Also break a huge number of those patterns. So that there is.
I bit more on the steering of my imagination. Into. What is possible and. There is an easy. Sharing of ideas.
Among some people like it here at the. Bush the era. You know there is not many towns where there is a theater.
Which is just sharing movies but where the guests.
Actually come and talk to each other for some half an hour before hand and. At interval.
And the end of always specially designed to be ultra long extended indigo in the middle of a movie so that everyone
talks to. Evers they're that they're friends of or other people they just mating.
And that the the whole movie experience is in fact as much a talking. Communal meeting place. Experience.
As anything else. It's almost like a church. Experience. So that's really beautiful. And the bush the at her in the.
In the just drowning here is something that's really special for me. Also i love this. But.
I love the factory as a building. I think it's quite grey and. It's got to be to full aka textual. Features and and.
And shape. The whole valleys. A very beautiful valley. I've got a very close relationship with the local.
Curry population and. I work with them and. I think that the whole valley still has a huge potential which it.
Just one does on. Disregarding and perhaps that. In the future.
That potential might actually be i wouldn't be utilised and really unleashed. And in between time i think i suppose.
It gives me. The chance to think about what. Individual communities across the world. Could be doing. Themselves.
And i love the neighborhood community level. You know i mean in the in the small thousands.
Maybe four to sixteen thousand. And in that field. How much what can a. Can and.
Community of that size really do for itself and how good a quality of life can it have.
And what are the economics of that. What is the reality of that. And what structures and ideas.
Have to actually be consciously working. For that to happen. Yeah yeah yeah. That's. Well i could just mention that.
Part of that sort of thinking of the. Four to sixteen thousand people. Is part of what i call a g.i. Village concept.
And it's related to. Ideas that i have a conceptual framework that i have which.
Go into any explore the question of how many people would you need.
Working in what sort of ways to have a post mechanical. Communities economics. Giving the i quality of life.
That includes the world. That keeps people in contact with and understanding. The latest ideas in the world.
And i will to actually put some of them into place. To actually utilize them and to work them through. What's.
What is the relationship. We've. We we've got some strong ideas now of what a nomadic. Community social economics.
Pattern is. And we've got lots of examples of. Agrarian. Such patterns.
And we've got lots of examples of mechanical wage. Patterns. But what that post mechanical. Pattern is.
Now and quite knows where. For you what you do with people. Jumping from one.
Idea to another from one project to another the. The. Linking the linking thing for myself is. Is understanding.
The reality is is a clarifying. And exploring all of. And testing out of.
And then trying to be very specific about what reality is how it works. And how it can work. Better.
And all of these different stories. Music oh yeah lane and all of these different things.
Sort of just fit in with a pattern that.
I explore in my brain trying to cope with this mad reality that we're stuck in and trying to simplify
and clarify it more than simplify. I think the complexities ok as long as we clear it. And clarify.
And make it easier to understand it doesn't need to be simple. We don't need to simplify things to the extreme.
We can cope with a pretty complex world. As long as we're clear about the complexities. Ok. So i thought. Monday.
And you know you guys you guys just do it.
I mean the tan during the equerries there's still a nine hundred seventy three license before or after.
You for a very quiet. Nice peaceful town. It's worth estimate. Just sight before.
And before the festival tallis very quiet place for women. Love it i thought loop. I was. Going downhill. I believe.
Ma business wasn't really paying. Well at that time. And the extra people it came certainly boosted it.
So what do you see. The first time i heard of it were. Three or four guys. In crime dunston one of them.
Arrived in to tear into the shop one day
and started to use what i propose to do that was the first thought heard of it sort of through all the sands
or i meant. You know i sort of didn't really know what they were getting at at that time. You know.
I think the biggest majority were for having this system will. There were two or three that weren't.
But they didn't voice their opinions if they were against it. If you did but not. We love. You know.
Not a real lot now and then i was there briefly but i didn't stay.
To them howl of the main thing
but i think the biggest percentage of the business people in that hand were sort of along the line just thinking oh yes
this could be good. It was prior to actually. Of course. Financially i thought you know would. Help us all. Oh yes.
Yes. There was a lot of activity leading up to it. But not a great.
Big lot of people are awed but there were a few running away and working in getting these together getting it together.
I think in the first.
Dial so i wouldn't think any of us realized that the name and would never have as many people in it you know.
Coming in buses and. What have you and of course everybody was.
Interest to be interested to see what they looked like and. Well first.
I was probably a little bit shocked that the way they dressed in the.
You know the state of their hair and the no shoes and the light sort of thing you know.
Most probably probably could say i was shocked. You know. Well.
I made a lot of really nice people and i got like a lot of people. My chin good friends among them.
And i was sort of they weren't as far as i'm concerned and.
In my business there wasn't a real lot of people who i disliked. There were a few. But not many. You know.
I really did sort of get on well with all of them and. I think they got on well with me too. So. Well you know.
Well i don't have many memories there are. Did was well that car didn't get out into the fields or at.
So had my shop actually. We worked from six o'clock in the morning till four o'clock in the morning some don't and.
I was sort of in the background or if i wasn't in the shop was at the bank over noising and.
So i sort of didn't say anything much that we don't like to the activities that we don't know. What was on the menu.
Just and we'd use in him the poison. Just. Just a lot of junk very popular. Yes well it certainly boosted. Business.
We didn't. Mike a real lot of money because we had to pry.
Too much wine why just to keep things flowing in and even right you know i was very very busy.
To get that stage i had during the festival employed twenty seven people. So i my self. So. Money didn't we.
My dad money but not a lot of money. So much. So as you know you know if i had.
Harry freeman in this was it after the festival.
I have a frame and had a few patients here who who wouldn't take their medication and.
He called out
and i sort of took over the job of making sure that these particular people we knew we had a medication up on a
cupboard and. When they come in of a morning. A lot of them up and gave them their medicine or whatever.
So let's stay on the probably. On a little bit of an even keel. So what's my schizophrenia explaining.
We said to say that at times when. You know when they were really. Off the beaten track.
And it was only purely and simply because they weren't taking the medication. So we. We sort of.
Tried to help them out as much as possible. About whether we were. Thank for it all went by appreciate it but we tried.
Yes i think that the tam didn't believe that as many people would study here we.
Well i personally thought that says the festival was i mean everything was cleaned up everybody would go didn't happen
did it.
You just don't think they realized that people would want to study you know i don't know where you are just one of my
impressions probably and i don't like the street scene at the moment.
I don't think that it's gradually going downhill but whether that had anything to do with the aquarius festival and no.
Probably not. I think that. In the last ten years with the peace. Scene in the street. Has actually gone downhill. But.
Doing the festival and.
I don't believe that there were any heavy drugs here there would drugs but i don't think you need heavy drugs
and i'm really. I'm a bit disappointed that the pan has turned. You know like it has you know.
I think the parents probably doing well financially as you know of the business of probably thriving now.
For all of the people that. But i hear in his diet he and i don't. Just.
Actually you know like what's happening in japan at the moment. Do you think it's so it was ok. Was it him.
I don't really know i wouldn't say it's a better tan i would think probably you know a lot so why is it easy. I guess.
Because maine is.
Employment in the area an ammo business and that sort of thing
but whether that can be put down to the fact that with the queries first of all that. My dad had been i don't know.
You know. Any idea what we're going to look i don't know. It probably would have died. I would say.
It was certainly on the downhill run before. As far as money making. Goes you know. Business area.
I believe it was on the downhill run. But. The general trend. Probably would have brought.
Different people he any help with the grace festival been healed
or not because fans all around the area would believe of me
and difference it was of come from the city to younger people to get a wife and also.
I think probably would have happened to nieman as in a certain extent in here. If you.
Was ever any thing to say oh yes they're still lees and.
Had to us know how to explain it mean that the still a lot of the older residents. Stand back.
When this any of the miranda i'd like excepting there has been a bit of animosity. You know. Cause.
It's a flare ups of arguments with different ones and.
But i don't sort of joining that scene anymore and sort of really know what is happening.
That they used to be a lot of the van tagging ism between.
The hippies in the streitz especially the guys that used to go to the pub. You know they'd be all the questions and.
What have you between them and a lot of them. Uncalled for billy.
But not really you know there's been so many little incidents that.
You know i don't really remember a thing but you know you hear back in the news you sometimes i had seen them.
Doing and. What have you. And. You know now i never ever did i always got on well with them.
I think i probably got more problems with accepting the. Pre-political here now who are coming into the area now that.
I mean they're not all bad. But i think i have no problem accepting them then i did back in seventy three.
I think it's. Maybe it's not. It might be but i know about them you know what i see and think going in and.
You know that you on drugs and that sort of thing i think that's what i sort of.
You know i find it hard to accept and then to try and be friendly
and nice to all paper let me ask whether they would be hippies or. Come straight to whatever.
It was really you know cancer of the moment or cancer or think of anything. You main.
During festival call after festival time no one. I would deem.
I don't really doubt one of the funniest things i saw wasn't funny but. It was amazing.
There were so many people in my shop and ours up and damning on the canton. And the walls were all.
Cream walls in this particular room where i used to. Gowns it made and.
I went in a half way through the morning one morning and they all got pictures. Drawn. I did all over them.
The were coming with their. Paints and brushes and. Painted pictures around the walls and.
Actually we left them a few years knees i don't know where they were got to with that.
But the shop after had to pull down front away but there was some very good.
Pictures that that was sort of set me back i think oh goodness me that didn't take long for that to happen.
It was interesting. But i can't really think of to know too much. So you know what. I think so. You know how much you.
Probably didn't change that much. Dried away. But i go i came in and.
Painted all pictures on the roofs and on the front of the shops and that sort of thing.
But that was some time off so it was a straight away. So you know. Yes so i had.
You know or my youngest boy it was one year. Oh. During festival time and i had two girls who lived with me.
And another son who's. He was that night. I got a lot out of the festival and said they would try the one year old did.
But. The girls did die. And i made.
Heaps of friends and sort of joined in activities when my head trauma from the shop and. I really enjoy.
I would actually just thing that last know if you know them both.
One more so than yeah those in there are glad i experienced it. You know. And.
But she was a little bit old and was old enough to probably appreciate what was happening around.
But the other one was the sort of. Appreciate it much but she said she's. Glad she experienced it too.
So you know that i grew up and. Yes. We didn't stop them from associating with the new settlers or. You know and.
They used to go visit people and. Dinners and then they places. I think probably. The boy. Let us letting them do that.
It's sort of opened their eyes as to what can happen to people and.
None of them ever wanted to sort of go in that direction.
But i think they could probably say you know that for what that last not for me.
You know they had the opportunity to do it if i wanted to but i didn't. So when you tell them you know just.
Just leaving in rags and and not coming your hair and.
Going shoe alyson that sort of thing they just think they sort of well you know i don't want to do that.
You know a guy had the opportunity to do it. Had i wanted to. But none of them have wanted to.
I'm actually glad about that. And you know. So there is that the children of the query and. You just put a few of them.
Can't recall any special. One but there are a lot of youngsters.
And there's a lot of youngsters who who have done well for themselves too and there's a lot that haven't hit
and who don't want to. You know that age group. When they happen to live on the street.
Call themselves straight kids but the biggest majority of their parents live here in here.
So i don't believe that there's even call a street kid a street kid if they parents leave in a year you think they've
got parents that's what that should be. I mean you know. So i had to i judge.